let me ask the fermi paradox question
let's say we live in this incredibly
dark and beautiful world of
just
billions of planets of bacteria on it
and very few intelligent civilizations
and yet there's a few out there
why haven't we at scale seen them
visit us
what's your sense
is it because they don't exist
um because don't exist in the right part
of the universe at the right time that's
the simplest answer for it
is that the one you find the most
compelling or is there some other
explanation
i find that you know it's not that i
find it more compelling it's that i find
more probable
uh and i find all of them i mean there's
a lot of hand waving in this we just
don't know
uh so
so i'm trying to read out from what i
know about life on earth to what might
happen somewhere else
and it gives to my mind a bit of a
pessimistic view of bacteria everywhere
and only occasional intelligent life
and you know running forward humans only
once on earth and nothing else that you
would necessarily be
any more excited about making contact
with than you would be making contact
with them on earth
so
so i think the chances are pretty
limited
and the chances of us surviving it's
pretty limited too and the way we're
going on at the moment the likelihood of
us not making ourselves extinct within
the next few hundred years
possibly within the next 50 or 100 years
seems
quite small
i hope we can do better than that
um
so maybe the only thing that will
survive from humanity will be ai and
maybe ai once it exists and once it's
capable of
of effectively copying itself and
cutting humans out of the loop
um then maybe that will take over the
universe
i mean there's a kind of inherent
sadness to the way you describe that but
isn't that
also potentially beautiful that that's
the next step of life
um
i suppose as
from your perspective as long as it
carries the flame of consciousness
somehow i think yes there can be some
beauty to it being the next step of life
and i don't know if consciousness
matters or not from that point of view
to be honest with you um
yeah but there's there's some sadness
yes probably because
um
because i think it comes down to the
selfishness that we were talking about
earlier on i i am
an individual
with a a desire not to be kind of
displaced from life i want to stay alive
i want to
be here
um
so i suppose the threat that a lot of
people would feel is that we will just
be wiped out so that we will be um that
there will be potential conflicts
between ai and humans and that uh that
ai will win because it's a lot smarter
boy would that be a sad state of affairs
if
consciousness is just an intermediate
stage
between bacteria and ai
right
and so i would see bacteria as being
potentially a kind of primitive form of
consciousness right so maybe the whole
of life on earth to my mind is capable
of some form of feelings in response to
the environment that's not to say it's
intelligent though it's got its own
algorithms for intelligence but nothing
comparable with us
i think it's beautiful what a planet
what a sterile planet can come up with
and it's astonishing that it's come up
with all of this stuff that we see
around us and
that either we
or whatever we produce is capable of
destroying all of that
yeah is it is a sad thought but it's
also it's hugely pessimistic
i'd like to think that we're capable of
giving rise to something which is at
least as good if not better than us as
ai
yeah i i have that same
[Music]
i have the same optimism
especially a thing that is able to
propagate throughout the universe more
efficiently than humans can
or extensions of humans
some merger with ai in humans
whether that comes from
bioengineering of the human body to
extend its life
somehow
to carry that flame of consciousness and
that personality and and the beautiful
tension
that's within all of us carry that
through to multiple planets to multiple
solar systems
all out there in the universe i mean
that's a beautiful
that's a beautiful vision whether ai can
do that or
uh bioengineered humans
uh can that's an exciting possibility
and especially meeting other
other alien civilizations in that same
kind of way
you